i have some of the most entertaining
video in a while
from i would say from the world of
politics generally
and that says a lot because it's 2018
and donald trump is president of the
united states
when they were in argentina for the g20
summit just a few days ago
donald trump and canadian prime minister
justin trudeau and mexican president
enrique pena nieto signed a new trade
agreement um during this trip
and the entire thing was just a complete
and utter fiasco which culminated
with donald trump signing the deal in
the wrong place and what i mean by that
is
trump wasn't in the wrong room he wasn't
in the wrong building he didn't sign it
in a country where he didn't have
jurisdiction that's not what i mean
i mean that he literally seemed unsure
where on the piece of paper
he should sign his name uh and the other
world leaders around him
were visibly confused as were the aids
and other people standing behind them so
let me kind of work up to that because
there's a lot here
the first thing that happened which i
just love is that canadian prime
minister justin trudeau
referred to trump as donald during the
press conference
about this signing which donald trump
just hates
and you're going to see donald trump
visibly displeased by this
and donald it's all the more reason why
we need to keep working
to remove the tariffs on steel and
aluminum between our countries
yeah so we're already off to a very bad
start but then we really get to the good
part and i know that this is a very
visual segment because we have audio
podcast and radio
listeners i always consider is this
segment
too visual for the people that are just
listening
this is one of those instances and i
apologize for that our audio audience is
not going to be able to grasp the full
insanity of this without
finding the clip online so i'll describe
to you what we're about to see
donald trump starts signing the three
copies of this deal
incorrectly and everyone else trudeau
the mexican president the dignitary
standing behind them
everybody looks extremely confused and
sort of wondering
like okay he doesn't know how to sign it
he doesn't know how to sign his name
what do we do do we say anything you'll
you're gonna see here people
visibly trying to hold in laughter i
would get the kids out of the room
because of the cringe here trump starts
looking around
and immediately you can see that the
other world leaders are wondering
what is wrong with this guy
let's go
they'll look on their faces
hahaha
each of us
extraordinarily bizarre and i'm not
going to subject you to too much more of
this but here's a much shorter focused
inversion
where you will actually see the key
moments of just absolute and total
bewilderment from the people standing
around donald trump
[Music]
each of us
pat when we say trump is a laughingstock
around the world it's not a figure of
speech
a couple months ago when trump spoke at
the united nations general assembly
the room of world leaders laughed in his
face
when he tried to talk about just how
great everything was how he has the best
presidency of any president in history
he's trying to sign a piece of paper and
other world leaders and dignitaries
are visibly bewildered by what the guy
is doing
this goes beyond anything we've seen
before doesn't it
yeah i love that video i like how at the
very beginning of it he's looking over
at the other documents
as if he's cheating on a test like
what'd you get for question number four
type thing
and also the pun enthusiast in me loves
when he goes
will trade i like that one too
oh yes because it was a traitor i didn't
even notice that that went completely
over my head actually and
i i would probably bet that it was not
deliberate by trump i think the guy
is not capable of uh of that kind of uh
of
uh pun what what is it it's not punditry
it's pun hun
he's not cunning nor capable of punting
i think i would say
why can't the guy just sign his name
correctly on contracts and treaties and
trade agreements and i would actually
suggest to you is it possible this is a
strategy
like imagine if all along donald trump's
strategy and business has been
i'm going to sign in the wrong place so
later
if there's any issue i can say i signed
on the date line
not where my name's supposed to go the
entire contract is invalid like is that
is that
something trump could be cunning enough
to carry off or is it just an accident
maybe that's how he gets away with not
paying the people he hires
and also his signature kind of looks
like a cardiogram like it's very up and
down
so i think people could look at that and
say that that's not someone signing
their name what
what the hell is that a lot of problems
with donald trump's signature more
problems with trump's signature
than any any president i can remember
bizarre video really the video should be
overlaid with the curvier enthusiasm
theme that's actually how the video
would make that that would be the
natural environment for that video check
it out send me your thoughts if you're
just listening
today's program brought to you in part
by blinkist.com
slash pacman blinkist is a great service
that i use all the time what they do is
they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them
into 15-minute audio books that you can
listen to
and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from
each book and i've listened to a ton of
books on blinkist
i recently checked out soccernomics
by simon cooper we do have after all the
world cup going on recently
we also have been talking about bs jobs
and there is a great new book
bs jobs by david graber which i listened
to
on blinkist they're constantly adding
new books to the platform
you will never run out of fascinating
and critically acclaimed books to enjoy
and our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blinkist.com
pacman if you're watching on youtube i'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you'd like
it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audio books for
about five bucks a month that's b
l i n k ist dot com
forward slash p a k m a n